JOSH LIVNI: Thanks for
watching, guys.
My name is Josh Livni,
I'm on the Maps
Developer Relations team.
And special guest
today, we have--
FELIPE HOFFA: Hello, everyone,
I am Felipe Hoffa.
I'm with the Cloud Platform
team, with the Big Data team,
specifically.
And specifically BigQuery, the
tool that allows you to query
millions, billions of records
in very few seconds.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, BigQuery
is amazing.
And I was watching this video
that you and Michael put on
last week about the new
correlations, Pearson
correlations, that BigQuery
magically
takes care of for you.
And it was a really
great video.
Tell me a little bit more about
what are correlations
and what you did.
FELIPE HOFFA: That was a
very fun video to tape.
To get out if you can, we took
70 million flights across the
United States, across
10 years of story.
We were looking for
correlations.
We were looking how to
predict the future.
How to know if you're flying
tomorrow from any airport in
the United States, how to
predict how late your plane
will be depending on what
happened today.
JOSH LIVNI: Pretty cool.
Pretty cool.
So I was watching the video.
You had the states that are
most correlated with each
other, lots of nice graphs
in matplotlib.
And then I was waiting for it,
I was waiting for it--
no map.
I was very sad.
But luckily, I was able to
track you down in the San
Francisco office, and in a
matter of like an hour put
together a map.
So that's what we're talking
about today is, let's say you
have a big data analysis
you're doing.
You have some output, it fits
into a nice spreadsheet.
Is it spatial data?
Why not go ahead and
put a map on it?
So this is what we did
with this blog post.
Fresh off the presses, Felipe
and I, talking a little bit
about how one takes some
output from BigQuery,
puts it on a map.
FELIPE HOFFA: We have up
here, let's look at it.
What do you do here, Josh?
JOSH LIVNI: What do we have?
So we have a lot of little black
circles on this map.
These are the airports that we
have lots of data for over
this 10 year history.
And go ahead and click on, I
flew out of Seattle last week.
Click on it.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's see what's
happening on Seattle.
So if I click here, I see a lot
of circles-- big circles,
small circles, no circles.
What do they mean?
JOSH LIVNI: What do they mean?
Yeah, so basically what we're
doing is resizing and
recoloring the circles based on
the correlation of airport
delay departure between today
and what we predict tomorrow.
So in this case for Seattle,
it means that if I'm flying
out of Seattle tomorrow,
what airport
should I look at today?
Probably Seattle, which
kind of makes sense.
FELIPE HOFFA: There is a very
high correlation for having a
[INAUDIBLE]
data point in this
time series.
There is a very high correlation
on what happened
yesterday in Seattle, predicting
what is going to
happen today.
JOSH LIVNI: Well, not that high
a correlation-- we're
like 0.47 here.
What if we change the seasons?
I know that there's sometimes
more correlations in different
seasons for different
airports.
FELIPE HOFFA: Whoa.
JOSH LIVNI: Airports, planes,
weather, kind of makes sense.
Yeah, so now at 0.7, that's
pretty good correlation.
Again, it just kind of makes
sense-- if you want to know
what's in Seattle tomorrow,
look at Seattle today.
Probably raining.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's a very
good way to predict the
future, whatever happened today
would happen tomorrow.
But sometimes there
are better ways.
For example, let's fly to
a different airport.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
I don't know, where did
you fly from recently?
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's
call San Diego.
JOSH LIVNI: Okie doke.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's
go to San Diego.
What do we have here?
JOSH LIVNI: A very different
pattern.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
Correlation size is smaller.
But this is interesting.
The biggest correlation
is not with San Diego
with itself but LA.
What's happening today in LA
predicts better what's
happening in San
Diego tomorrow.
JOSH LIVNI: Maybe that
makes sense.
LA's kind of the
hub down there.
So this is kind of
interesting.
Small correlations distributed
kind of evenly throughout the
country, unlike the West
Coast, Seattle.
What happens if you
pick a major hub?
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's go
to the East Coast.
How about New York, JFK?
JOSH LIVNI: OK, so lots of
stuff, bigger circles, bigger
correlations on the
East Coast.
It's kind of interesting.
JFK's not even in the top five
for predicting what JFK's
going to be like.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
very interesting.
If you want to know what is
going to happen in JFK
tomorrow, during spring,
look at what happened
in Nashville yesterday.
JOSH LIVNI: Nashville
predicts JFK.
I love it.
So yeah, you can click around
this map, kind of see some
distributions of how the
different airports are
correlated with each other.
It's kind of interesting.
Change the seasons around,
have some fun.
And this was super easy
to put together.
Why don't we hop back
to the blog post?
Just take a quick look at the
code, and talk a little bit
about how it works.
FELIPE HOFFA: Please show me
how you're doing this.
This is great.
I love it.
JOSH LIVNI: Well, of course,
all of the code is
available on GitHub.
If you click through to the map,
you can view the source.
But we also have a short gist
down here showing the main
functions to recolor things.
It's pretty easy.
I have a method down at the
bottom, the get icon one that
passed in the scale of the
correlation, and a color to
color [? by, ?] say,
red versus black.
Let's get back a circle.
It's pretty easy to
draw circles on
a map, that's useful.
And then the other thing is
just highlighting the
correlations.
Looping through all of the hard
work that Felipe did to
give me the results of
the correlations.
And then go ahead and just say
for each airport get the
appropriate icon back.
Not super hard.
Not a lot of code to create
a map like this.
We started from a template
visualizing earthquakes that
we put a really basic article
on that you guys can start
with if you have different
size circles.
And more importantly, if you're
doing some big data
analysis and there's some
spatial aspect to the data, go
ahead and make a visualization
that has a map with it when
you're finished.
FELIPE HOFFA: I love it.
Thank you very much for
doing this, Josh.
JOSH LIVNI: Thank you
for doing all
the hard work, Felipe.
My job was easy.
FELIPE HOFFA: Well, your
job is awesome.
So anyway, remember, if you have
spatial data and you like
it, put a map on it.
JOSH LIVNI: I love that.
Quotes to live by.
Felipe, thank you very much.
I'm Josh.
FELIPE HOFFA: And I'm
Felipe Hoffa.
Goodbye.
JOSH LIVNI: Cheers.